hello everyone
welcome to this special webinar where we
will be discussing
projects related to infectious diseases
research
in today's session we'll talk about
research projects
developed for this program
bioinformatics for
infectious diseases these include
research proposals from the participants
and
updated resources on the following
topics
origin and pathogenesis of the novel
coronavirus
mutation frequency in the ebola virus
genomes collected during the 2014
2016 epidemic linking drug resistant
variants in tuberculosis mycobacterium
enterovirus epidemic in children and
contamination of biologics production
this session is part of our
bioinformatics for
infectious diseases online training
program
designed for biologists clinician
students
interested in biology microbiology and
immunology
for this program we have collaborated
with the dokuchi memorial research
institute
for medical research at the university
of ghana
today we are joined by the research
group at nobuji as well as the
participants of the program
in the context of infectious diseases we
will also be discussing some of their
projects
and learn from their experience
let us start by taking a look at the
current progress of some of the
participants who are
here in the program as indicated by
the point system that we have for all of
our omics logic program we can see how
our participants are doing
and completing this first phase of the
program
successfully we started
phase one which focused on the following
topics
analysis methods and tools for genomic
in transcriptomic data analysis of
host pathogen interaction methods to
study relationships based
on local and global multiple sequence
alignment
phylogenetic analysis and evolutionary
studies
used for genome ancestry and population
fitness
chemical and structural implications of
sequence variation
mapped on pdb models host pathogen
interaction
and treatment response bioinformatics
for infectious diseases
is a six-month online training program
where we are learning about the use of
bioinformatics and big data for
infectious disease research
the program ends in the summer after the
first phase is
over we will go on to do an
in-depth training in transcriptomics
and genomic data
the next phase is going to focus on
in-depth training
in genomic data analysis this will start
on march 12
2021. the registration is now
open and anyone with an interest can
sign up
i am posting the link in the chat right
now
for the next phase of this training
so this program also comes with
scholarship opportunities
for students the scholarships we offer
are designed to help motivated talented
and promising students
benefit from special training and
research opportunities
the criteria for approval include a
reasonable need
indication of extra effort that the
participant is willing to put into the
program
and time commitment needed to go beyond
the regular training
this will likely include keeping a
regular record of topics
covered in a detailed lab journal entry
and participant in student facing
presentations
about the learned drop topics
now let me introduce you to the program
mentors
and principal investigators we have dr
harpreet kaur who is a certified omix
logic trainer and expert by information
she guides the hands-on sessions and
assists participants with projects and
analysis during the program her area of
specialization is in genomics and
machine learning
dr mohit mazumdar is the omics logic
project mentor and an expert in big data
computational analysis
he has a phd in computational biology
and over 10 years of experience
working with industry and academia
we also have dr anita gansha who is
a senior research fellow and lecturer
at the nogochi memorial institute in the
university of khana
she is leading the projects as part of
the bioinformatics for
infectious disease program i will now
like to
invite dr mohit masundar to talk
more about the upcoming program and his
experience with
research projects related to
bioinformatics for
infectious diseases over to you dr
mazuda
thank you and hello everyone
let me share my screen real quick
okay
so hello everyone yeah so one of the
major focus of this program
uh bioinformatics for infectious disease
research and training
is to support ongoing research projects
uh that
are spearheaded by dr anita gansha's
group at noguchi
and her collaborators having a long
history of research
in ghana and other countries in
sub-saharan africa
to track monitor diagnose
and study the spread of drug resistance
malaria
as well as identify noble approaches
to for vaccine design
for as well as interactions between the
malaria host
vectors and pathogens to help conduct
such research
so bioinformatics
offers tools data repositories
and analysis techniques that we are
covering in this training program
so i've been working for the past
several weeks collecting resources
for malaria omix data so today i wanted
to just review
uh the compilation of the data resources
and the scientific literature associated
with omics data for malaria research
so to compile this article and you can
see the link below here and be sure if
you can share the link with everyone
here as well
so to compile this article we reviewed
uh publicly available data sets
generated by by using
next generation sequencing and uh we
looked into case studies that
demonstrate the utility of sequencing
techniques
and how it correlates to the
drug resistance in malaria by looking at
multi-homics data
by looking at the entire system uh
biology aspect and then diving into the
structural biology of the
by looking at the protein and its
mutations and the structural
biology involved in it so
uh so the objective of this review is to
provide
examples and starting point for students
and researchers
who are interested in bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
and especially the genetic diversity
diagnosis
and for the treatment of malaria
so today i wanted to wanted
all of us to take a look at some of the
popular repositories and the
resources listed in the post so the
first
uh image that you can see here is
european
ena or the european nucleotide archive
so
by searching the term plasmodium uh we
care we
kind of find out numerous results for
omix data
uh on omix data for this parasite so
this involved uh includes like here you
can see 170
assemblies and over 4 400
000 sequences and almost 34 000 uh
experiments with 30 000 sequencing runs
so a reference of genomes annotation of
genes
examples of transcriptomic studies so
this is an invaluable resource for
anyone interested in malaria research
using the
oh makes our big data so second another
repository is plasmodb
it's very popular uh and is a biological
data database for genus plasmodium
so the database is a member of the eu
path db project very very popular
project
so this data set and this database
contains extensive
genome proteome and metabolom
information
related to the malarial parasite
so another repository this is here uh
the malaria
host pathogen interaction center i mean
actually it's not
just a repository that they host but
but this mah pic team
they strive to deliver unique large data
sets
i mean that holds potential for major
breakthroughs that ultimately will
advance our understanding for malaria
and help diagnose prevent and treat the
disease so this initiative or
innovation or innovative is a design of
infectious studies infectious disease
studies
and they're using computational tools to
integrate clinical
parasitological functional genomics
proteomics and
lipidomics and also metabolomics data
so all of these repositories and their
links and even
the data sets are uh are listed in that
article that has been just uh shared
so uh then uh thinking about in the
sense of
transcriptomics analysis so
transcriptomics analysis of
samples uh obtained in this human
challenge studies
can also help us deepen our
understanding of the immune response
uh with that symptom onset allowing that
characterization of innate immunity and
all
also that early gene signatures that
almost always influences the disease
outcome
so gene expression studies uh are
actually helps
and facilitates the identification of
host factors that are contributing in
the disease susceptibility
so one of the places i mean to look for
data that can provide
insights and answers related to gene
expression of the gene
related to the expression of the genes
that can characterize
like this process of infection is the
is the nc ncbi gene expression
omnivorous
geo so geo is an international public
repositories
uh repository that archives and uh is
freely distributed
uh microarray data is there uh ngs data
and other forms of high throughput
functional genomics data
are like regularly submitted by the
research community so these all
information and much more is available
there you can look at
uh and then as i was telling you that
next we looked into a case study
uh so this case study
uh involving plasmodium falciparum
resistance to chloroquine in
chloroquinine so the
as you i think everyone knows that
formal
it's a former gold standard for an
anti-malarial
drug and now has a
mutant form uh which is causing the drug
resistance
uh basically due to the chloroquine in
uh resistance
transporter gene so pfcrt so
in this uh here on the
on the left panel you see that there is
a bio project
so a bio project uh is a compilation
which is available
uh under ncbi so here we found out about
one data set that has been processed uh
with this mutation that is uh
cost that uh caused the you know uh
that uh caused the mutation at that
position and amino acid so it's leucine
at 275 272 uh position
changing to phil phenin and and the
mutation was identified at
uh cytosine uh at 814th position
changing to thiamine
so we traced that using the structure
also which is a cryo-em structure
submitted in
pdb protein data bank but this data set
we found out in
ncbi um and they used i think
um blastocydin uh pressure which
resulted in this mutation
at the coding region so you can find out
all these information
in the blog post and we are expecting
that
out of this resources you'll be able to
find uh some of the key questions that
you have interest in so one of the
objective
of this program or this uh you know
this webinar
is to be able to help those who are
starting
in this journey so we have prepared
these articles and projects and we are
looking for research project ideas
and proposals to leverage these
resources and multi-omics data
for noble insights into the spread of
the disease and
as i told you that prevention measures
that can
help address this pressing challenge
across
africa to and to talk about more i mean
uh it makes more sense and it to talk
about malaria research more i would like
next
like to invite dr anita gansha to talk
about
her research and the program
so far
thank you for this listening to me and
let me know if you have any questions
related to the
resources and the approaches and the
multi-omics
integration approach that we are taking
and then we are looking into the
structural aspect
so i will be happy to answer your
questions you can reach out to me at
mohit at the ratepine.bio
so i'll be also sharing that in the chat
and now i would like to
hand it over to anita to say a few words
thank you mohit let me
share my slides
so good afternoon to you all um today
i'm not going to really talk about
the studies i have conducted but um
as we began this journey i think
a few weeks ago in january
we've been thinking about projects that
we want to
undertake to finish this
first part of the training
and so at this point some of the
participants are ready to
present um studies that they are
thinking about
this is just um ideas that are still
being
crystallized and so with time you're
going to
develop it further and to
kick start this i have decided to look
at
um investigating
similarities and differences in post
responses
to saskatchewan and plasmodium fossil
from infection
and i'm going to do this with dr bright
edu
and we are looking for others to
collaborate
right so a bit about malaria is that
malaria as
mojit has said is a parasitic infection
caused by parasites of the genus
plasmodium
and transmitted by the anopheles
mosquitoes
the infection leads to acute and
sometimes life-threatening diseases
and it is a major public health concern
although
it hasn't got that much attention um
in 2018 about 228 million
cases of malaria were reported and
405 000
deaths and most of these occurred in
sub-saharan africa with children
under five forming the majority of with
the
morbidity and mortality
we all know the coronavirus disease
covered 19. it's also very infectious
and a global pandemic and everybody is
interested in it
and it's caused by the severe acute
respiratory syndrome
growing up virus to sasco ii
and when i checked last night we had
already had
over 100 million cases and then
2.4 million plus
deaths globally now
there are some similarities between
malaria and covid19
symptoms or the symptoms of the
disease some of these include the favor
and fever breathing difficulties
tiredness and acute onset of headaches
and this may lead to
misdiagnosis of covid19
for malaria especially in the malaria
endemic
regions and vice versa
this particularly is seen where
a lot of the malaria um
diagnosis relies on just the symptoms
and
i can speak for ghana and a lot of
african countries
we self-diagnose and go to pharmacies
and get
a treatment based on these symptoms so
it's very likely that we have missed a
lot of the covet 19
now as a result
and many many more reasons
we are sure there is a low prevalence of
kobe 19 in malaria endemic countries
and this is what was not originally
expected
considering the fact that these two
infections
may have similar symptoms and you can
imagine
the co-infections with covered in
malaria
may be complex
so some of the reasons that have been
assigned to the low prevalence of kavit
19 in malaria endemic regions are
the age structure there's a lot about
the fact that covet 19 is most prevalent
in um elderly people
and the age structure in africa
is more youthful than in the
western world so
people over 80 or above 65
who seem to have other underlining
conditions
are most affected by covet 19.
but um we've seen that
the age bracket for covet 19 is lowering
with this second wave of the infection
but there's a whole area that is still
being unraveled
now as i've said there are similarities
between the
copy 19 symptoms and that of malaria
so you can imagine that the immune
responses that
people who have been repeatedly infected
with malaria may be playing a role
in preventing
very symptomatic or severe covet
infections
in the malaria endemic regions and some
of
these rules have been assigned to the
is to
in malaria and covet basically because
the
angiotensin ii
[Music]
that is um that has been
catalyzed by the ace
is found both in covet 19
and also protecting malaria infections
and then the role of interferon and the
neutralizing antibodies
in malaria and covid19 has also been
postulated
to contribute to the low prevalence and
the use of
hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine and
cov19 there's a lot a lot of controversy
around that but um
this may also contribute to the low
prevalence as we keep treating
people with these drugs in sub-saharan
africa or malaria endemic regions
but we also know that the co-infections
with
malaria and covid19 could
the interactions can or would expect it
to
rather worsen the disease phenotype
so
the problem that i think we have to
unravel
is the fact that even though we have um
significantly lower coveted 19
in malaria endemic regions
we you may be expecting war we're
expecting
co-infections to be more harmful
and although the role of the h2 receptor
interferons and neutralizing antibodies
have been postulated to be involved in
the low incidence of
kobit 19 in africa the full spectrum of
the host similarities and differences
in response to both infections has yet
to be
unraveled so we are proposing to conduct
a
comparative differential gene expression
analysis
on available rna-seq data on the host
cells infected with plasmodium
pulses from and subscribe to the overall
objective
is to elucidate the significant
similarities and
differences in gene expression profiles
and the underlining biological and
molecular mechanisms
specifically we want to conduct a
differential gene expression analysis on
starscope 2 and malaria infected human
cells red blood cells and there are
other cell lines too
and then we're going to control for
transcriptional features
shared by suscoff2 and other viral
infections
such as sas mess and h1n1
just to make sure that we are dealing
with covet 19
in our analysis that will determine the
similarity
between the transcriptional features of
subscript 2 and malaria infected cells
and when we have found these
differentially expressed genes between
these two
diseases will conduct um gene ontology
analysis
to look for the significant molecular
and biological functions involved in the
host
responses to sas group 2 or
covet 19 and malaria
we are expecting to obtain the full
scope
spectrum of genes and pathways involved
in both
covid19 and malaria
and then to describe the
molecular and biological functions and
aligning the similarities and
differences in the host responses
to covered 19 and malaria
and then we look at the potential
synergy between these host responses to
covet 19 and malaria
so
we have data sets from three studies
one is looking at repeated infections
in children the transcription
or transcriptional profile of children
who have been repeatedly infected with
malaria and then the other one
study two has got the
transcriptomes of um
individuals and cell lines infected with
subscribe to meres
h1n1 and then the third study
has got red blood cells infected with
malaria plasmodium fossil from parasite
and the transcriptome
analysis of that and these are the
references
thank you very much
thank you anita i also have a question
is anyone else from your group
ready to present because i think i need
to make them composed to do that
yes i think that um courage and
um nigel
will also present their way and
ellie okay
so okay i i've made
courage the co-host next so courage if
you would like to share
and about this uh thank you for the
presentation anita was really
interesting
um i wanted to ask uh there
seems to be a clinical trial that is
just getting started
um are there cases that you know of that
have both malaria and cobain
you mean places i mean you would expect
to see that in sub-saharan africa
because are you aware of cases where
people actually got both diseases at the
same time
well i haven't really really looked at
that but i'm sure
bright who has all the data can tell us
that
unless they haven't tested but the
samples are there
and they can be quickly
screened for malaria yeah
okay they must be very common yeah
you think it is common yeah because
about
20 25 of people in
at least ghana is symptomatically
infected with um
malaria so it's very likely
okay great thank you very much
hello everyone i hope you are doing fine
and everyone see my screen
so my name is uh carriage adobo
and uh i'm proposing approving yet for
these uh causes we are taking
a genetic variation studies of session
stitch specific antigen
pfs 230 and pfs
48 and 45 of plasmodium fasciculum
population in ghana
yeah okay
so we know malaria is uh caused by
malaria caused by plasmodium falciparum
is one of the most
deadly form of malaria especially in
sub-saharan africa affecting millions of
people and
especially children under the age of
five so control
interventions against malaria have seen
the use of anti-malaria drugs like
artemisinin
and previously grouping stuff and then
there are also other vector control
measures but what
is lacking among these tools is a
broadly effective fasting
the currently most advanced malaria
vaccine
rtss has shown
low efficacy in clinical malaria
this low efficacy studies have shown
that is largely due to the genetic
diversity of the targeted
antigen which is the second sporozoid
protein
now transmission blocking vases
will induce responses against
the malaria para sites gametocytes
sexual stings thereby blocking
fertilization and
protein reproduction two antigens
pfs 230 and 48 and 45
which i expressed on the surface of
gametocyte have been shown
in research papers
that they elicit strong immune responses
however genetic diversity of
these antigens have not been fully
explored
in the ghanaian parasite population
so the problem is the efficacy of
current
malaria vaccine are hindered due to the
diverse nature of
the antigens
and to have a successful transmission
blocking vaccine
it will have to induce the immune
responses against the malaria parasites
at the gametophyte stage however the
genetic diversity of
transmission blocking vasons vase in
antigens have not been fully exploding
the ghanaian population
so there is the need to therefore
explore the genetic diversity of this
transmission blocking antigen to further
estimate how effective vassens will be
if they target those antigens
so the objective
of the project is to scan for
genomic regions inside these antennas
and then find variations in them
in the population and then identify the
types of mutations that these variations
cause and further see whether these
mutations the functional effects they
have
on the translated proteins
so i'll take my data set from
[Music]
malaria gene the public
like the community projects and this is
the url
to the various data sets
references thank you
and uh correct you just had a question
uh were you going to work on this on
your own or is there anyone else that
you're planning to work together with
so i've not found i've not gotten any
partner yet
so for now i'm working
on it alone but i'm looking for partners
okay so you're open for others to join
you with there
right yes
okay and uh so i guess at the end of
this session we can talk more about
what it would be an effective way to
partner on these different project
proposals thank you
if anyone has any questions or comments
on this please
feel free to add those
and if for anyone else that's going to
be presenting if you could just start
off with just a few words about yourself
uh your background kind of uh you know
how you ended up getting interested in
this project
i think that would also help others uh
consider how they may contribute
so you know if your background is in
bioinformatics or your background isn't
uh something else i think it would be
more easy for people to see what they
can contribute
thank you courage so i assume the next
person would be
benedicta
um can someone else present our
presentation
okay who who else is ready to present
one second
okay nigel i made you a co-host
all right thank you very much
hello everyone and my name is nigel
dolan
i'm a research assistant at the gucci
university of medical research
and my background is in bioinformatics
i'm working under doctor
who is my supervisor on my api and
my background in mathematics entails
nutritional drug discovery
and regulatory disease like
ulcer and tuberculosis
leprosy and then also
malaria and so this projects that i'm
thinking about
is regards to malaria and it's
a competition guided approach towards
the discovery of natural product
compounds resistance to
pfmrd1 and pfcrt
these are two gene mutations which have
been known to confirm
this artemisinin resistance and
plasminoposal
so the background malaria which is a
protozoan
infection is caused by plasmodium
parasites and this remains
a major cause of mobility and mortality
worldwide primarily
primarily among children less than five
years old
and yes in 2018 it was estimated to have
caused
around 220 million cases globally of
which 90 percent
which is which constitutes and 13
million africa
now the mafia can see shows and physical
malaria
parasite prevalence in africa and the
presence of children
infected with phosphorus so in if in
blue
and blue yet blue blue shows the low
areas
where we might see one routine better
children out of hundreds
whilst in all in high areas which are
which indicates by red
it might be more than 50. now this alone
demonstrates how and change the disease
remains throughout much of
western central africa and parts of the
articulation
however this is not a gloom as they have
been therapeutic gains
in trying to kept this minutes the
recent and current frontline therapy is
that the missing
base combination therapies or the acts
and these have been invaluable
in the substantial decline of the burden
of malaria
the challenge yes again yet again
however
the two main pillars for malia control
and
beyond remaining targets in the
unoffline muscular vector
and effective case management which is
crucially dependent on the efficacy
of the deployed and smaller drugs here
in acts
yet there's a green contender that says
it starts to question the efficacy of
the therapy there have been reports of
treatment failure of activities in
southeast asia
and this parasite is just relentless
i must say antimaterial drug resistant
in plasminophob tends to image
in low transmission settings
in particular in southeast asia or south
america before expanding to high
transmission
settings in sub-saharan africa
arrival in sub-saharan africa of these
very difficult to treat parasite strains
can have a huge impact on malaria
mobility metabolites and yes
they have arrived
the course mutations in 2014
reports established that resistance
attention is due to
the count propeller domain of the
process however
importance of this study are the pf
crt and then pfmdr1
so allows of plasmodium phosphorus
chlorine
resistant transportation which is the
pfcrt
have been assisted with chlorine
resistance and plasma phosphorus
and then the plasmodium multi phosphorus
phosphorus multi-drug resistance that's
the pf
mdr-1 gene it's also associated with
both chlorine
and ammoniacon resistance
so you you'll see in this image here
that the parasite which is shown in gray
a grey oval is shown within the red
blood cell which is in red
the dv which is the digestive vacuole of
the parasite
it's a comparison within a process where
the catabolism of hemoglobin
from the post art vessel case
the breakdown of hemoglobin results in
reactive pain which is toxic to their
parasites
and undergoes detoxification to to
become
hemozone now medications from
chloroquine class bind him and interfere
with detoxification
here
but pfcrt
and pfmdr1 which which are dv
or digestive vacuum membranes
proteins it starts that the pfcrt
transports drug out of the the dv
while the pf mdr1 transports drugs
into the db now the mutation in the pr
pfcrt is essential to chlorine
resistance
while that's in the pfmdr-1 is essential
to
to augment also chlorine resistance
and mutation in these transporters have
been found to mediate the resistance of
atomy
at a missingness and that's the goal
this product therefore seeks to
virtually screen multiple neutral
compound libraries from different
databases
first of all to identify compounds which
could potentially have final affinities
against both the wild and mutants
pfmdr-1
and pfcrt now to what end is this the
end of which is to identify compounds
which could potentially circumvent the
resistance of regions
pf mdr1 and pfcrt so that at the end of
the day we would have
new compounds that would potentially be
moved to become drugs
that would address the issue of
resistance
regards to this process and the menace
we should produce malaria and so these
are my data sets
and my references thank you very much
okay great thank you everyone uh or uh
sorry
thank you nigel uh would you be also
open to others contributing to your
project
all right excellent thank you very much
um
so again the process for anyone to
contribute to these projects
either from the participants of the
current program you know
everyone involved for those who are not
a part of the pro
program of this program we're going to
discuss the upcoming program
on genomic data analysis as well as
the research fellowship if you're a part
of the research fellowship we can also
probably match
with somebody who you're interested to
contribute to and it will be up to them
to decide
if they're open to that contribution um
who would be
um are there any questions sorry for uh
nigel
okay if there's not who would be the
next person presenting
hello i have a question yes
yes my name is so my question
thank you nigel for the wonderful
presentation so i was just thinking
your project is time to look for
compounds that will
inhibit those two genes both the white
and the
mutant genes now
how are you going to get data that will
show that will
have an array of compounds to test
since we are looking for compounds and
or is that that data that
has all of the possible compounds which
you can actually test for
thank you thank you very much are you in
dm
i was something else i forgot to add to
this and so
this study is also compressed because at
the end of the day and
i'll be looking at the band affinity of
those compounds regards to an atomism
and so how well they do determines um
and whether or not we are going forward
with those particular components
and then so and zinc database was
measured
for the data set string database has a
catalogue of
compounds which in the substance of
which
are some of them are from africa so
you'd have for db which has a catalogue
of
a number of compounds and so
my research is targeted towards
compounds that are from africa
that are going to screen um against
these genes
then see the ones that perform better
than
atoms and go forward with it yes so this
is just a clear mistake
yeah thank you
all right great um thank you um
benedicta would you like to go next
yes please hello hello i also have a
question
okay just for the sake of time
if we could move on to benedicta but we
you can post your questions
in the chat and we'll make sure
um to uh you know share the contact
details so
for you know more questions after that
okay
all right thanks thanks a lot okay thank
you anytime
go ahead benedict
okay benedict are you able we cannot
hear you or see your screen
okay benedicta can you still hear us
okay maybe it seems like she lost
the connection i feel yeah lost the
connection
okay so um maybe we can
continue and she will join back uh we
also wanted to
explain a little bit more about
how these projects are formed
and how anyone can get started with a
project
even without having a lot of information
on bioinformatics and other things
if you've been addicted joined back
benedict can you hear us
okay so um
i don't know if i can take it from here
and introduce everyone
to the research pollution
okay great thank you thank you
so as uh many of you are interested in
collaboration
or looking for opportunities of how to
work on projects like this
we have this research fellowship program
so i want to thank uh dr gansha
courage and nigel for presenting we are
looking forward to seeing their projects
fully fleshed out
for the remainder of the bioinformatics
for infectious disease program
participants of the training
and our other research fellows will be
collaborating together with our mentors
and experts from the topper
bioinformatics research center on
completing the analysis
and to give everybody a sense of how the
research component of the program works
i'm going to be sharing a few more
slides about the research fellowship
program that we have
so one of the main challenges that we
have seen
from many researchers students as well
as research fellows who are starting
their bioinformatics work is to prepare
a research plan that fits with the type
of data
and leverages big data analysis tools
effectively
so we have a step-by-step process
which guides our research fellows and
helps them understand
the logic first and then apply it to
their own
research question
so as a result anyone starting on this
journey in bioinformatics can start
developing a project
of their own in fact we have already
worked with many students who have
completed the training and developed
interesting research projects which have
won
awards and even got published in peer
reviewed
journals so here are some of those
projects
by our graduated research fellows
who have worked on these different areas
of bioinformatics research
yes and for all of you who are showing
your interest
in the chat box please put your email id
down
or please email us at marketing at pine
dot bio or
africa prime dot bio so we also have a
team in africa who
support us who support the biotech team
so
you could also reach out to them and
thank you fiza for
sharing so as i mentioned many of the
past participants had the chance to
present their analysis in front of their
classmates or at a conference
in poster sessions or workshops so here
is an example
from one of such conference that we had
in baton rouge in louisiana
so where we presented on different
topics
and here was a presentation by our team
so to help participants reach this stage
of a complete project that they can then
present
to a larger audience we work with them
through the steps of the project design
so we have these different steps that we
have in the project
design process that we work with each
one of the participants so each research
fellows goes through this process
starting with learning about the
different multi-omics
topics then completing certain tasks
related to them
then starting their literature review on
an area that they are interested
in researching on working to find
data sets which would be apt for the
kind of
problem that they are trying to solve
and finally
going forward with their analysis that
presentation
presenting to an audience like we have
today
with a wider audience of people getting
it reviewed by our
experts at the topper bioinformatics
research center and then
finally taking it to a stage where it
can become a publication like you see
here
so this is a very step-by-step process
and the research fellowship is offered
for a period of
either three months minimum or a period
of six months
it can go in longer but what we aim to
do is that we start this process by
training
each research fellow making them
familiar with the topic making them
familiar
with the research that is going on in
the different domains
so it can be anything it's not just
infectious diseases you can be
interested in oncology
you can be interested in precision
medicine like to see this project here
so there are a lot of opportunities for
everybody
interested in different topics we also
have a working group right now who are
working on
alzheimer's so there are these different
opportunities available for
everyone that you can explore as part
of the research fellowship process
and for example this is a project that
was developed by dr gansha
in collaboration with dr emika patrick
chubbucka
in part of the research fellowship
program where they were looking at the
analysis of transcriptome profile of
sars cop2 infected cell lines
to understand the mechanism of action of
repurposed drugs for coped 19 treatment
so as you see dr gansha has already
spoken about
how we are looking at the different uh
prevalence of kobit 19 and malaria
across regions in africa so this was one
of the projects she worked on
related to over 90.
so now to help those who are starting in
this journey
our team has prepared several advanced
research projects that anyone can
take to learn more about genomic and
transcriptomic data
in application to various pathogens i
would like to invite dr
core to present some of the new projects
that are available right now
on our platform dr carr over to you
thank you
so hello everyone my name is harpreet
kaur and i have a phd in bioinformatics
in my current role i am a mixed logic
bioinformatics trainer with the pine
biotech
so here i am assisting participants to
learn about data analysis
machine learning and visualization in
the application to the large dataset
used in the biomedical research so
besides i am
involved in designing different research
projects using publicly available data
with our team members at
find biotech here we are continuously
designing different research projects
using publicly available
data based on the studies published in
high impact journals
thus we have collection of project where
you can learn
how bioinformatics can be applied in the
field of infectious disease
using publicly available ngs data
so the first project here
is on ebola so as we know ebola virus
cause a deadly ebola virus disease in
the human which is also sometimes
referred as
ebola hemorrhagic fever so for out of
the six
known ebola virus cause life-threatening
viral infection in the
humans which is also highly contagious
so the recent epidemic outbreak in west
africa has raised concern
about the implication of this virus on a
human population
so here we have designed a dedicated
project on ebola
based on the original publication data
to understand
its reason and to find out what are
important mutation of the variance
that are for this particular malignancy
sorry for this particular output
so during the 2014 to 2016 outbreak of
the ebola in the west africa happened
across different
regions the next generation sequencing
can be used on the last scalar to
large scale to track the development of
this epidemic
so here we used genome sequence data
from the ebola virus stream to perform
msc and the phallogenetic analysis
so we use multiple sequence alignment
and
phylogenetic analysis to determine the
evolutionary relationship
between these genome so
we have identified a group of samples
and how they are related to its
phenotype
so the phenotype that we choose here in
this case is its
geological location that is the country
from where it is originated
like gabon liberia or uk
next we also see how we can analyze
multiple sequence alignment and
nucleotide label
and amino acid label to understand the
differences
and the mutation among different samples
so we will learn what are the key
mutation in a specific reasons
that result alteration in the
pathogenicity
so we also analyze mutation between
groups of the sample using comparative
analysis to study mutability
so this smell method helped us to
identify the origin of polymorphism
which is
believed to a cause of an increase in
the ability of virus to enter the
host cell
and the next project is on kobit 19.
so when this kobe 19 pandemic outbreak
happened so there are the several
questions
questions arise that needs to be
addressed
so these questions can be like from
where it is originated or
from which animal or from which location
it is originated
so how it start infecting humans
so for this purpose to understand this
we have designed
a project on covid19 that is reason in
the pathogenesis of novel coronavirus
so here first based on the multiple
sequence alignment and the phallogenetic
analysis
we will try to understand its genetic
unity reason that is
from where from which animal it is it
has been originated
so in this you will learn to perform
phylogenetic analysis
to understand the reason whether how it
is associated with the
other strains of covalent 19 as well
so then multiple sequence alignment will
help us to understand what are the
measles
differences and the variations taking
place between the different strains
of the covid19
so in the next part we will also learn
how and we can obtain uh what are the
different key components
or the protein components in the virus
and the host that are responsible for
its patho density for instance
to a receptor winds to spike protein
so how you can visualize the structure
of this protein
and it's complex with the east to spy
uh is to so how you can
understand the differences between the
different reasons in the structure
so we have incorporated this part as
well
in the next part we also we will also
have try to incorporate transcriptomics
data analysis to identify
a signature that can discriminate
the sample that are ruxin rexella native
treated and untreated samples
so here we have employed different data
exploratory analysis approaches like
differential gene expression analysis
principal component analysis
and hair clustering to understand what
are important signature
that can distinguish these classes of
the samples
then the third project is about
tuberculosis
so here we have designed this project to
understand the
drug resistant variant in the
mycobacterium
as we know one third of the world
population has been infected with
tuberculosis so this tuberculosis is
caused by mycobacterium tuberculosis
so this disease has see uh severe
symptoms including chronic curve blood
present in the sputum
than the weight loss etc but the major
concern with the
tuberculosis is the drug resistance in
the mycobacterium
so there was a research work was
published
in the one of the top journal that is in
lancet
so where they authors have performed
whole genome sequencing for the
prediction of the mycobacterium
tuberculosis drug susceptibility and
resistance
in this study authors sequenced a
training set of nearly
2100 mycobacterium tuberculosis genome
so we have taken this data so
in this project we have employed various
jivas approach to
identify those genes that are associated
with the
drug resistance here mainly we use
gamma plink and the slope methods
then the next project is about
enterovirus
d68 out to be so one of the diseases
that is
acute flaccid myelitis which is a severe
neurogenic disease in the children
caused by
this evd 68 virus
so this afm disease is like a polio
light
defined by the acute onset of flaccid
paralysis
in the setting of spinal mra
demonstrating a longitudinal lesion in
the gray matter of the code
so in this project we have tried to
understand the evolutionary relationship
between the strains
from various outbreaks of avd 68
which are occurring at different time
points based on the ngs data
so it is first immersed around 1968
but in the last decade this outbreak of
evd60 has been rep
evd 68 has been reported across the
different parts of the globe
particularly in the u.s and the europe
like after every couple of years
like 20 uh it first recently it was
happened like 20
of uh 2012 and 2014 2016 and so on
so there they have also observed the
pathogenicity
of this particular virus is actually
varying among different outbreak
outbreaks so here we have used multiple
sequence alignment
as well as various phylogenetic analysis
using different phylogeny tree
reconstruction
algorithms to find out whether ebd
strains
from the different outbreaks at
different points are the same
or the different based on the
phallogenetic and
multiple sequence analysis
and further we have identified the diff
how they are different based on the
phallogenetic analysis
then the multiple sequence alignments
indicate there are
number of the variations occurring in
this in these strains
but not all the mutation transfer to
transfer at the amino acid level still
there are like two to three percent of
the
variation state taking place so
participants can explore all these
projects and
learn about how you can employ various
bioinformatics approaches
to analyze ngs data from various
infectious
pathogens so that's
all so now i would like pass this
session back to the pipsa
so over to you thank you so much uh
dr harpri so i want to take this
opportunity to
invite you all to see where the projects
that dr harper
just introduced is on the platform so if
you are again joining us for the first
time
please come with me to edu tbi info i
will be posting this
in the chat box right now so once you
are in this platform
you will notice i'm already logged in so
you'll find
if you're not logged in either a
register or a login button
and you can register with either or
email id or there are also
registration via any of your social
media ids
so please go ahead and register
and if you're already on the platform
please put down number one
in the chat box so that i know that at
least some of you are there
in the platform and you can explore the
resource that i'm showing
along with me so please put number one
in the chat box thank you emmanuel
anybody else who is on the edu platform
thank you martha and courage and
elizabeth
anybody else thank you nigel
so we already have a lot of you were in
the platform
and also part of this training program
okay thank you saida so let us explore
the first free resource
now i know that many of you who are
present in today's meeting have already
taken this course
but for anybody who is joining us for
the first time we recommend you to take
the introduction to bioinformatics
and the reason is this course introduces
you
to the different opportunities available
and we encourage everyone to take the
course so that
you can go ahead and take a take the
intro survey
which gives us an idea about who you are
and what your interest is so this helps
us to
collaborate with you on your area of
interest and provide you
those opportunities which are available
in the area you're interested in
so the next step is to find the project
so if you
note in the projects if you click on
this column it will open up to this tab
so these are the projects that dr
has been showing you
so let us
see the projects which are there so we
discussed tuberculosis
covert 19 the ebola project
and here are the direct links so some of
these projects
like the kovit 19 project is free
and available for everyone to start
taking the project
so i'm posting the direct links but you
can again go from the project section
right here
and you can see more or you can just
click here it will lead you
to this project page and as i mentioned
that these projects are not just
on infectious diseases there are more
projects on different
areas you have projects also on cancer
and oncology which are here so
please feel free to explore these
projects
and if you want to study what other
participants have done
in the previous program i'm going to be
sharing with you
a link to the project examples
so here is the link to project examples
from
our previous participants who have taken
part
in such training programs and have
successfully
done a project so most of these
participants who have
been featured in this project example
page are
our research fellows so they have done
some
of their work and it is featured here
many of them
are going towards working on a
publication
are working on writing a paper so
these are the different projects that
you can see and they
cover different areas and applications
of
bioinformatics to different kinds of
data sets
so please feel free to explore this page
as well and as for the next steps like
what are the different
options that i have that you have to
join
a program like this so as i mentioned
earlier
so you have already the upcoming
genomics program as part of the next
step
or the phase two of the bioinformatics
for infectious disease program and
this is open for registration if you are
interested
we have already also mentioned the
research fellowship
the next program which is available is
the omits logic transcriptomics program
so this is a program completely on rnac
data analysis so if you are interested
in learning more about
ngs data then this is a program for you
the other program which is ongoing so
this program
has already started on february 16th but
you can still enroll for the program
if metagenomics is an area that you're
interested
in learning and this program is also a
collaborative program
with an institute in nigeria called the
helix biogen institute
so this program had have only two
sessions so far
it's open for registration so you can
also join this program so we are
covering different comics topics as part
of these programs and another program
which is starting very soon from march
15
is a program on precision oncology
so we are going to be studying example
data sets
and talk a lot about cancer and the role
of precision medicine
in understanding a disease like cancer
and here are the different
links to enroll in these different
programs
so let me quickly share with you the
links so i believe that there is a lot
of links
if you are interested in something
particular please
let us know i'm going to be sharing all
the
pages where you can actually enroll for
each of these programs
so please feel free to login to these
pages and enroll for the program
so i think uh business thank you beeps i
just wanted to mention
uh to all of those that are already uh
participating in the infectious disease
program
uh you have until the end of today to
finalize your submissions
of your project proposals because we
will need at least
three days to review all of the project
proposals
with our collaborators at the top of
bioinformatics research center
and with dr ganza so that we can
finalize it by our next session on
friday
and if you have any questions about your
project proposal
if you are finding it difficult to find
a data set
or you don't really know if there is
something that you would like to
focus on consider joining one of the
proposed projects that we saw today from
nigeria
from dr kansa from courage
i don't know if benedicta is still
wanting to present her
project but those would be
projects to consider to contribute to
and then also
uh one of these projects described by dr
who showed these are projects that you
can start with
but then you can expand on those by
adding additional data sets
or trying some of the other example
methods that you've learned about in the
program that we are doing right now
so benedicta would you still like to
share
and yes if you can hear me now yeah we
can hear you
great
can you see my screen yes we can
but you probably should change the
screen because we see your presenter
view
okay
you can change it right above where it
says display settings you can just do
okay see it says swap
yeah okay
so the title of my project is looking at
the structural
patterns of diversity and selection of
plasmodium falciparum ethical membrane
puts in
one gene in ghana and also across
multiple populations in the world so my
name is
benedictsa so
um i have a background in biochemistry
epidemiology
and biostats and then somewhat knowledge
and bias that is
in bioinformatics sorry i still have
biostatistics here
and my research interest is in
molecular and genetic epidemiology
more specifically looking into
infectious diseases
and non-communicable diseases such as
cancer so this project is
an extension of my phd work where we did
sequence the
epic memory protein and a little
background
into that is the ethical membrane
protein is
a transmembrane protein that is um
released um into the surface of the
nerves like
protein during inflation of neurozoids
into
um erythrocytes that's the rpcs
and some studies have shown um it's been
under selection by the immune system and
is one of the primary targets for
malaria person and development and to
effectively
prevent malaria and subsequently
eradicate there's a need for us to
develop an empty
malaria person so the aim of this
product is to look at
the genetic diversity of the ama1 gen
and whether this is balancing selection
or immune selection
and also to um look at the structure
of the pfp in new engine and
to see whether the variations that we
see in ghana
and also variations that we see in other
parts of the world like
um south east asia and south um
eastern africa to see whether this
affects the
protein structure also functions such as
immune selection
so um the product summary involves
looking at
diversity indices such as nucleotide
sequence diversity
haplocyte diversity the amino acid
sequence diversity and also look at the
group the protein structure in this
folding
look at fsd and genetic structure for
instance looking at
pcas to see whether these genotypes
um cluster differently for the different
populations such as
west africa and then also some other
parts like
southeast asia and also to determine the
evidence of selection using
a day and also um from this
course i've learned how to do the 3d
profiling of protein structure
so that's what this main product i would
be focusing on to see
whether um differences in these
nucleotides affects the protein
structure
and whether this also affects how
these different genotypes would
functionally select by the immune system
so i will use data that we have
generated here at
ngs data and also data
from a project that's the malaria gen
where they sequence
the whole falciparum genome for
multiple countries so i would extract
data of the
our the ama1 gene data from those
projects and then
compare to see um the indices that i
have indicated to see what how they
differ between the ghanaian populations
and then also other populations
across the world thank you
thank you and so can you just describe a
little bit better specifically what type
of data you mentioned you have your own
data but there's also this publicly
available data
um so what exactly do you what type of
data is this
so it's a genomic data of plasmodium
falciparum
gene just that one gene so it's
amplified
for that gene no it's it's the whole
genome
of fossil production so i'm gonna
extract the ana1
gene and then compare
and what kind of metadata is available
for that data
um is it just resistant
non-resistant or is it also resistance
to different types of drugs or anything
else like this
so as as to and this is
a malaria project so it's just it
sequence the whole genome and then you
can
um decide so i have the link to the
project but i
am interested in looking at the ama1 gym
so
i'm not sure what kind of metadata they
have
there but i'm sure
there's a sequences of the whole genome
so
okay are you uh interested
in others potentially contributing to
your project
yes
all right great thank you very much
anita did you want to
add anything to that yeah i was going to
say that the
malaria gen project does not really
have available meta
data just the location of the
um some poles and sometimes
the level of prosthesia but if one is
interested then you have to
apply and then you know the
resistance status or information
about the clinical study
that went with the data what are you
people doing
officially
okay thank you for that clarification
anita so if anyone has any questions
about this project
uh or how to join i hope that we were
able to answer all of those questions
and again just to kind of summarize
this webinar this webinar is a part of
our ongoing program
this program is designed for research
kind of transitioning into research
by those who have received the training
that we have
and we also have a number of
other programs and resources that beeps
mentioned so
beeps i'll pass it on back to you to
wrap it up
thank you so much uh dr manson thank you
elia
and also dr ganza so as we are ending
today's session i want to ask if you
have any questions and
as you see on my screen right now i'm
sharing our linkedin page
so this is also a group where we
collaborate with a lot of
participants from all over the world so
please
feel free to go ahead and join the group
i've posted the link
in the chat box and we also have a
similar
facebook group here as well so any of
these social media channels that
you feel comfortable in please go ahead
and follow us
and you will also find snippets of
uh of what we do shared in our instagram
page and by infomatrix fine so
you're able to find us on all of these
social media channels
so please continue to follow us in any
of these places
and we hope that you not only follow us
but
also gain something out of this we share
interesting research articles from time
to time
we talk a lot about our programs we talk
a lot about the job opportunities which
are there especially on our linkedin and
our facebook groups
so please feel free to take advantage of
this
opportunity and see if you are also able
to
share with our other members something
that you feel
interested in and you can have a
conversation
so what we intend with our community
here at pine biotech is that our
bioinformatics community
can not only learn from a program like
this
or collaborate on projects but they
continue to learn
from each other and collaborate with
everybody who is present in that group
so fizza has a question are all the
projects discussed here
a part of the bioinformatics research
program i mean do i need to register for
every course individually
or overall registration is required so
all the projects that are mentioned
here would be available as part of the
research fellowship
program so
what you need to do is that when we
start the research fellowship program
with you you would need to specify a
particular
area now there are a lot of projects
that i have shown you
say for example uh there was this ebola
project
so if you're particularly interested in
one project we would be
working to make sure that you are
learning all about
ebola now you can definitely do
other projects but what we try to do as
part of the research fellowship or any
of our training programs
is to make sure that you're focused on
one particular direction because
firstly as i uh mentioned while i was
presenting that
it's not easy always to come up with a
particular uh
form of analysis find the right data set
so those are some of the struggles that
we see
every research fellow um
notwithstanding what their educational
qualification is or how much they know
they struggle with because these are not
easy to come up so you are going to
spend
a lot of time on one particular topic so
yes you can
choose any of this research projects in
fact
the projects that we mentioned as part
of the examples all of those projects
are novel research projects
which means that we have not proposed
those topics
so the projects that you see here have
been proposed by these
students or these participants who have
taken part
in the research fellowship program so
they propose the projects
and they can only propose the projects
once they go through this entire process
of
training learning going through the
different
example projects and then understanding
that okay so once i've learned from here
what are the different
opportunities to explore this in a
different
research question so that is exactly
what the research fellowship is about
so you can choose any of these topics
now coming to
iorinda's question can one still join
this program despite having started
since
january and would end in a few days so
irene as we mentioned that this is a six
month long program which we are doing
with noguchi
now the first part of the program
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
is going to be over you cannot join that
program now
the next program that we have and you
can join
is the omics logic genomics program so
this is
phase two of the program where we are
going to be talking about genomic data
analysis
in respect to bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
so it's a continuation of the training
program
and the next again the training that we
are going to be talking about
is transcriptomics so you can still join
this program which is going to be
starting on march 12th
it is completely open for registration
so
you have not been a part of the first
part of the training but
as if you see this program and its
syllabus
it starts with a very introductory
session
so we have broken down this entire six
month program
into different parts and you can still
take part in this program as we are
going to be starting right
from like you can say stage one
and building up your understanding of
genomic data
and how to work with that kind of data
so here you can find the different
uh syllabus for the program so you can
see the different dates which are there
the different topics that will be
covered on each of these dates
so you can definitely join this program
again
so do we have any other questions that
you
want us to address right now because we
are almost
close to ending today's session
and again if you still have some
questions uh
and if you do not have them right now
please feel free to reach
out to us at marketing at bind dot bio
so okay so for emmanuel's question
which is about metagenomics so
metagenomics started
i mentioned on february 16th so we have
had only very two introductory session
and our next session is not until
tomorrow
so tomorrow is going to be like the
third session so
we have just started so if anyone is
interested we welcome you to go ahead
and join the metagenomics program as
well
so this is like i feel it's a wrong link
so if you have put in your email address
i think email
we have already shared with us the email
address we will be
sharing with you the details and as i
mentioned we also have a team
in africa so let me share with you the
correct
address i think adidas has also shared
it in the chat box
so you can also reach out to the africa
team
at africa at pine dot bio
so if you go to the
okay let me share the email id again in
the chat box
right so what i wanted to show you is
that we have had only
this introductory session and this
session on
microbiome is a functional bacterial
community
and the next session is going to be
tomorrow
so if you're interested please go ahead
and join and if you need more
information you can reach out to either
of these email ids
so you can reach out either to me or
to adidas africa pine dot bio
and thank you aditya for sharing this
so i hope that this is all clear to you
we are having several different programs
uh that suit different research
interests
so you can reach out to us uh and i hope
that
with all of the different programs
available you are not overwhelmed
because if you
are you are again can ask us questions
and i think we will be able to help you
address some of those questions so we
had a question regarding like data
science program
so we had just concluded a data science
program as
uh like in january so that program
started and has already ended
now if anyone is interested in doing a
data science program
you would have to go through the
research fellowship process which means
that if you're part of the research
fellowship program
we are going to be doing the same kind
of training we did as part of the data
science program
and you will be going through those
similar resources on machine learning
and data science
and you can take the program again
because we do not have any upcoming data
science program which is
dedicated to it like we have for media
genomics or transcriptomics
i hope that clears everybody's doubts
and regarding all of the details so once
you fill up the form
we will be sending you email regarding
all the details on how to join the
program
and as i mentioned earlier for each of
the programs we
do offer scholarships so the
scholarships are offered to students
who like who present that
they are able to take up the additional
responsibility of
attending each of the sessions sharing
with us
updates of their progress so if the
student has to be very dedicated so once
you submit one of these scholarship
applications what we do is
we invite you and one of your reference
to a one-on-one meeting
where we meet with you explain to you
how the program
works and what you would be required of
you
so if you are able to agree you are
offered that scholarship
and this can either be a full
scholarship or a partial scholarship so
this
completely depends on like how you're
coming
and like presenting yourself so that
would be completely dependent
and then we would be sending you an
email regarding this
so if you're applying for the
scholarship position or you need
help with the scholarship you can again
email us and we'll be sending you the
details
so whenever you are emailing us please
mention the name of the programs as we
have mentioned quite a number of
programs here
and we would love to help you with the
program that you are seeking so please
mention the name of the program you are
wanting to
apply for and we will be helping you
with all the details it is either myself
or adio
we will be the session is recorded uh
a fun so we will be sending you the
video of
the session
if there are any questions
thank you aditya
so i welcome you all to join either of
the training programs and collaborate
with each other yes the fellowship
program
also has a fee so
if you go to this link you will be able
to see all the details
of the fellowship program i'm again
sharing this
in the email or if you fill out the form
you will also receive an email which
will have all the details
so if you click on get started you can
see what are the different fees for
either the three months or the
six months program so this is the
standard fees and again the scholarship
option is available
so please feel free to reach out to us
with either of these
options and thank you all for joining us
today
i hope that you have a lovely week ahead
we look forward to seeing you in the
upcoming
sessions programs and seeing your
projects and thank you to all the
participants
in the bioinformatics for infectious
disease program who made time
to present today we look forward to your
projects as well
have a lovely day everybody thank you
you